In the last video we went over
the multiplication tables for 1
through 9 and I ran out of
time, and actually, it was a
good thing because 1 through 9
are kind of the core
multiplication tables.
And you'll see that if you know
all your multiplication tables
from 1 to 9, so you know any
number between 1 and 9 times
any other number between 1 and
9, you can actually do
any multiplication
problem out there.
But what I want to do now
is I want to complete the
multiplication tables
for 10, 11, and 12.
So what is 10 times--
let's just start with 0.
10 times 0.
Anything times 0 is 0.
Ten 0's are 0.
0 plus 0 plus 0 ten
times is still 0.
What's 10 times 1?
Well that's just 10 one time.
Or 1 plus itself ten times.
That's 10.
I think this is second nature
to you at this point.
What's 10 times 2?
I meant to switch
colors, but I didn't.
10 times 2?
That's 10 plus 10, which is 20.
Fair enough.
And notice, we went up
by 10 the first time.
We went up by 10
again to get to 20.
What's 10 times 3?
Well, that's 10 plus 10 plus
10, or we could view it as 10
times 2 plus another 10,
which is equal to 30.
What's 10 times 4?
I think you start
to see a pattern.
10 times 4 is equal to 40.
Notice, 10 times 4
is equal to 40.
If I were to tell you what
is 10 times-- let me
do another color-- 5?
Well that's equal to 50.
10 times anything is that
anything with a 0 behind it.
So the 10 times tables
you almost don't
have to remember it.
So let's just keep going.
What's 10 times 6?
It's equal to 60.
6 0.
What's 10 times 7?
70.
10 times 8?
This is almost ridiculous.
10 times 8 is 80.
10 times 9?
90.
10 times 10?
Now this is interesting.
So it'll be a 10-- let's
see me write this.
Let me do it in
this orange color.
10 times 10.
So it'll be ten 10's or a
10 with a 0 behind it.
There you go.
Notice everything-- whatever
times 10 I just add a 0 and
then I get the next number.
So it's 100.
And I think you
understand why that is.
I added 10 to itself ten times.
That each 10-- you
go from 10, 20, 30.
30 is just three
10's or 10 times 3.
90 is just nine 10's
or 9 times 10.
Let's keep going.
So 10 times 11 is equal to
11 with a 0 behind it.
110.
Finally, 10 times 12
is equal to 120.
Now, just for fun, these are
kind of your 10 times tables.
But now that t know the
pattern you can do anything.
If I asked you what 5,732 times
10 is, what's it going to be?
It's going to be this number
with just one more 0.
So it's going to be-- I
won't read it out yet.
5 7 3 2 with a 0 behind it.
And just so you know, this
little comma that I wrote in
the number there, that's
just to make it easier for
me to read that number.
And you put the comma-- you
start over here and every third
number you put the comma.
So here I'm going to put
the comma right here.
I'm going to put the
comma right there.
So now I can read this.
The comma doesn't really add
or take anything away from
the number, it just
helps me read it.
Now 5,732 times 10 is 57,320.
i just had to add a 0 there,
but that was a pretty
straightforward multiplication.
And notice, we had 5,000 times
10 and we got to 50 something
thousand when we
multiplied them.
So that's similar to 5
times 10 is equal to 50.
But instead of 5 I had a 5,000,
and so I got a 50,000 and
something and all
this other stuff.
We're going to learn more
about how to do problems
like this in the future.
But I thought I would introduce
you to the idea that just from
this little pattern of adding a
0 you already know your
10's times tables.
Now let's do our 11's.
Well, they start off easy, and
then they get a little more
difficult as we get
into high numbers.
11 times 0.
This is easy, this is 0.
11 times 1.
This is also easy.
It's 11.
11 times 2.
We're going to start
seeing a pattern here.
It's 11 plus 11 or we could've
added 2 to itself eleven times,
but that is equal to 22.
If we do 11 times 3
it is equal to 33.
11 times 4 is equal to 44.
I think this is becoming
obvious to you.
What's 11 times 5?
11 times 5 is 55.
Notice I put the 5 twice.
What's 11 times 6?
It's 66.
11 times 7 is 84-- no.
I'm kidding.
I didn't want to mess
with you like that.
But no.
Of course, it's 77.
You just repeat
the number twice.
Let me switch colors.
11 times 8 is equal to 88.
11 times 9 is equal to 99.
Now what's 11 times 12?
Oh sorry, I skipped 10.
11 times 10.
You might want to
say it's 1,010.
No.
That's wrong.
It's not 1,010.
So that little pattern that we
had where you just repeat the
number, that only worked
for one-digit numbers.
So it only worked
for 1 through 9.
11 times 10?
Well, we could think about
it a couple of ways.
We can add 11 to 99.
So we can say it's 99 plus 11.
And what's that?
That's equal to 110.
And I'm going to show you how
to do-- well, hopefully you've
already watched the video on
how to add two-digit numbers
like this, but that's 110.
Or you could just use the
property from the 10's times
tables that we learned where if
you just take 11 times 10 you
add a 0 to the 11, you get 110.
That's the 11 right there.
Finally, let's do 11 times 12.
No easy way to remember
this, you just kind of
should remember it.
Or you could say look,
it's going to be 11 more
than 11 times-- sorry.
I keep skipping things.
We should do 11 times 11 first.
Let me make sure this is clear.
We're doing 11 times 11
before we go to 11 times 12.
So 11 times 11 is going to be
11 more than 11 times 10.
So we add 11 to this.
11 plus 110 is 121.
And actually, as you'll see,
there actually is an order as
we get to higher multiples of
11, but I'll leave that
to a future video.
And then finally,
we're at 11 times 12.
And we could add 11 to
itself twelve times.
We could add 12 to
itself eleven times.
Or we could just say, hey,
is going to be 11 more
than 11 times 11.
So that is what?
You add 11 to this.
What do you get?
You get 132.
I just added 121 plus
11 and then got 132.
Now the other way you could
have said it is, well,
what's 10 times 12?
We already knew that.
That was 120.
So 11 times 12 because we're
multiplying 12 by one more
should be 12 more than that.
So that should be 132.
So two ways to get the
exact same answer.
All right, now let's do
our 12 times tables.
And once you know this you
are ready to tackle any type
of multiplication problem.
But we'll do that
in future videos.
So 12 times 0.
Super easy.
0.
12 times 1.
Also super easy.
Is 12.
Now it gets interesting.
We're going to increase
by 12 every time.
12 times 2 is equal to 24.
12 plus 12 is 24.
12 times-- not 22.
Let me rewrite that.
12 times 3 is going to
be 12 plus 12 plus 12.
Or we could write
that as 12 times 2.
I see my brain is doing
the wrong things.
We could rewrite that
as 12 times 2 plus 12.
Or we could rewrite
that as 24 plus 12.
Either way, all of
these get us to 36.
And notice, that's
just that plus 12.
12 times 4.
12 times 4 is equal to 48.
There's a lot of ways you
could think about it.
You could say 11 times 4 is 44.
And you go up by one more 4,
so you get to 12 times 4.
Or you could say 12 times 3
is 36 and you can add one
12 to it to get to 48.
Either way works and that's
because you can multiply
in either direction.
Let's keep going.
12 times 5 is equal to 60.
10 times 5 is 50, 11 times 5
is 55, so 12 times 5 is 60.
12 times 6 is equal to what?
It's going to be 12
more than this.
It's going to equal 72.
12 times 7.
12 more than this again.
12 more than 72 is 84.
And I'm serious, I'm probably a
lot older than you are and I
still, in my head to confirm, I
go to some 12 times tables that
I remember as definitely right.
Like oh, 12 times 5-- and
sometimes in my head I say,
oh, let me add another 12.
Oh yeah, definitely, my
memory was correct.
12 times 6 is 72.
All right.
Then you go to 12 times 8.
Add 12 to the 12 times 7.
96.
12 times 9 .
Well you add 12 to
this, so it's 108.
And then 12 times 10.
This is an easy one.
We just add a 0 to
the 12 to get 120.
Or we could've added 12 to 108.
Either way.
12 times 11.
We just did this.
You add 12 to this
you get to 132.
And then 12 times 12
is equal to 144.
And this actually shows up.
If I had a dozen of a dozen
eggs-- a dozen is 12.
Or if I had, I think a gross
is actually 12 dozens.
So that's 144 eggs.
You'll actually end up
seeing this number a lot.
More than you would
expect in life.
But anyway, we've now
completed all of our
multiplication tables.
And I really encourage you
to take the time now to
go and memorize them.
Make some flash cards.
Use the little software thing
that I wrote on my website.
You could try that out.
As of September
2009 it's working.
I haven't touched it in a
while, but I'm actually
probably going to
rebuild it soon.
So if you're watching this
video in the year 2200.
Well, I would probably
not exist anymore.
But hopefully you'll get
a better version of
the software app.
But you should practice it.
You should get your
parents to quiz you.
You should get notes cards.
You should just be mumbling
to yourself as you walk to
school-- what is 12 times 9?
What is 11 times 11?
And you should quiz each other
because it'll pay huge rewards
to you later on in life.
See you in the next video.